digamos que esta casa ha estado en venta
desde hace varias semanas y el precio de
venta es de 310 mil dólares y ustedes
dicen bueno justamente este es el tipo
de casa que yo estoy buscando es una
casa en la que me veo viviendo con mi
familia así que me gustaría comprarla
pero ya que esta casa ya tiene un tiempo
en el mercado yo creo que puedo obtener
un precio mejor que éste así que ustedes
deciden hacer una oferta iba a ser una
oferta por un poquito menos de lo que
piden por 300 mil dólares y aquí la
cuestión es cómo es que ustedes o su
agente de bienes raíces se van a acercar
a estas personas para realizar esta
oferta realmente la forma en la que se
hace no es llegar directamente con el
vendedor o con el agente del vendedor y
decirle sabes que yo te ofrezco esta
cantidad ya que estas personas no saben
si ustedes están hablando con seriedad o
si es que de verdad tienen ese dinero
que están ofertando o si es que ustedes
nada mas están haciéndoles perder el
tiempo o jugando con ellos y para
demostrar que ustedes no están
lo que se hace es crear un contrato de
oferta vamos a ver qué es lo que lleva
este contrato de oferta ustedes o su
agente si es que tienen contratado un
agente inmobiliario o incluso podrían
encontrarse estos formatos en la red y
llenarlos por ustedes mismos bueno este
contrato de oferta debe tener cierta
información básica información sobre la
propiedad que están interesados en
comprar datos sobre el comprador ustedes
y el vendedor y es para especificar de
qué se trata este contrato también se
tiene que poner información acerca de la
oferta que se está haciendo por la
propiedad así que nuestra oferta es de
300 mil dólares y además ustedes quieren
demostrar que están hablando en serio
que esta es una oferta seria y honesta
así que ustedes van a hacer un depósito
junto con este contrato de oferta
y la cantidad de depositar puede variar
claro que mientras más alta sea esta
cantidad en el depósito pues más
seriedad están demostrando ustedes de
que si tienen intención de comprar esta
casa lo típico para estos depósitos es
que vayan siendo alrededor del 1% 2 por
ciento 3 por ciento 4 por ciento o
incluso hasta 5 por ciento del precio
que se está ofertando para la casa el 3
por ciento es el que yo he visto más
común pero no tiene por qué ser a fuerza
el 3% esto es sólo un indicador para el
vendedor de que ustedes son serios
haciendo esta oferta así que justo en
este momento van a escribir un cheque
que van a entregar al mismo tiempo que
el contrato de oferta por digamos en
este caso el 3% del precio de oferta el
3% de 300.000 va a ser 9000 en algunos
lugares no es necesario que eso sea un
porcentaje de la cantidad se puede dar
son una cantidad cerrada como adelanto
como depósito pero nuevamente este es un
cheque que se está escribiendo se está
expidiendo junto con el contrato de
oferta y muestra que ustedes son serios
con esta oferta que están haciendo que
de verdad tienen la intención de comprar
esta casa y si por cualquier razón
ustedes no cumplen con su parte de este
contrato el vendedor tiene el derecho de
quedarse con ese dinero que ustedes le
dieron como depósito así pues al
demostrar que ustedes van en serio con
esto pues invitan al vendedor a que
considere este contrato de oferta y en
su momento cerrar la venta de esta
propiedad en un vídeo futuro veremos con
más detalle a qué se refiere con cerrar
la venta y ustedes pueden decir bueno no
voy a comprar esta casa así como así si
bien me gusta la casa me gusta el
vecindario y todo parece estar en buenas
condiciones no estoy 100% seguro de que
esto está realmente en buenas
condiciones así que yo quisiera tener
una oportunidad de inspeccionar esta
casa de poder traer algunos expertos
revisen y me aseguren que la casa está
en buenas condiciones para asegurarnos
de esto lo típico es agregar en este
contrato de oferta una sección de
contingencias
contingencias las contingencias típicas
son cosas como inspecciones
a lo mejor quieren revisar que no haya
termitas revisar los cimientos e
inspeccionar la tubería la instalación
eléctrica y asegurarse de que todo se
encuentra en buenas condiciones si algo
surgen durante la inspección que les
haga cambiar de parecer con respecto a
esta casa les va a permitir cancelar
este contrato de oferta y si todo sale
bien puedes recuperar el dinero que
dieron como depósito otras cosas que se
pueden poner en contingencias es que
bueno ustedes piensen que van a poder
tener un préstamo para completar los 300
mil dólares que están ofertando quizás
ustedes tienen ahorrado el 20% de esta
cantidad lo suficiente para el depósito
y un extra más imaginemos que ustedes
tienen ahorrado 60 mil dólares o quizás
70 u 80 mil dólares ya que necesitan
dinero extra para los costos de cierre y
algunas otras cosas de las que
hablaremos en futuros vídeos no sé a lo
mejor también tienen que comprar muebles
o algo así por lo que tienen ahorrado si
esta cantidad pero necesitan pedir
prestado necesitan un financiamiento
para completar la cantidad que falta
típicamente quién está el dinero para
hacer estas compras es el banco y los
bancos normalmente les dan una carta en
donde revisa en sus ingresos su
historial crediticio y si el banco se
siente en confianza de que les puede
hacer ese préstamo de que ustedes tienen
lo necesario para pagarlo en su momento
se les crea prueba el financiamiento el
préstamo pero está pre aprobación no es
lo mismo que tienes ya la aprobación
real algo podría suceder de manera que
el banco quizás se dio cuenta de algo
que no había visto antes y que y que
cancela la pre aprobación del
financiamiento o quizás cambiaron las
condiciones del financiamiento entre el
momento en el que ustedes obtuvieron su
pre aprobación y el momento en el que
realmente ya necesitan que les den ese
dinero así que otra contingencia típica
es el financiamiento ustedes dicen bueno
yo de verdad quiero comprar esta casa
pero no podría hacerlo a menos que
reciba un financiamiento o un préstamo
bancario otras cosas que pueden estar
aquí en las contingencias son los
seguros y bueno está de los seguros no
es muy típico por eso le pongo un
asterisco aquí pero a lo mejor la casa
se encuentra en lugar que es propenso a
las inundaciones y el antiguo dueño
tenía un seguro contra inundaciones pues
porque era amigo del agente de seguros y
las compañías de seguro no están
generando nuevas pólizas de seguro para
esa zona por su tendencia a la
inundación
otra contingencia obvia es lo de las
escrituras ya que es algo que se
necesitan si es que se quiere comprar
esta casa y nuevamente veremos en otros
vídeos más detalle esto de las
escrituras o los títulos de propiedad y
esas son todas las cosas que si por
alguna razón cualquiera de estas fallas
pues nos permitirá deshacer este
contrato de oferta ahora si ustedes se
encuentran en una zona residencial que
es muy demandada que muchas personas
quieren vivir ahí y hay muchas personas
que quieren comprar esa misma propiedad
y algunos de ellos están haciendo
ofertas muy buenas muy jugosas para
comprarla no sé quizás están ofreciendo
pagar en efectivo o están ofertando
otras cosas entonces no es raro quitar
algunas contingencias de aquí
que desde el punto de vista del vendedor
ellos están buscando a los compradores
más serios si alguien está dispuesto a
quitar algunas contingencias y les digan
bueno quizá es una locura pero yo estoy
dispuesta a comprar esta casa así tal
cual cómo está eso hace mucho más
atractivo para el vendedor ya que él
tiene la confianza de que esa
transacción no va a verse truncada
debido a algunas de estas contingencias
pero esto sólo se da en zonas que son
muy muy buscadas y donde mucha gente
quiere vivir pero en un mercado
inmobiliario más típico y yo les sugiero
que hablen con personas con expertos en
esta área para que ustedes sepan qué es
lo que está sucediendo en el mercado que
a ustedes les interesa es más típico
tener ese tipo de contingencias
especialmente las inspecciones el
financiamiento y las escrituras
y la última parte de esto en donde
quizás ahorita no estoy entrando a mucho
detalle y en futuros vídeos veremos un
contrato real de oferta ustedes también
van a querer indicar la fecha límite o
la fecha de cierre así que no sé
imagínense que este contrato de oferta
se generó el 15 de octubre del 2015 y
supongamos que ustedes quieren cerrar
este contrato que todo esto se realice y
otorgarle al vendedor la cantidad
completa de dinero que están ofertando y
también obtener la escritura de la casa
con una fecha límite digamos de dos
meses después de que se hizo el contrato
de oferta para el 15 de diciembre del
2015 nuevamente desde el punto de vista
del vendedor mientras sea más cercana
esta fecha límite o esta fecha de cierre
se sentirá mejor porque tendrá más
confianza de que esta transacción se va
a realizar si quieren hacer una oferta
muy tentadora para el vendedor pongan la
menor cantidad de contingencias posibles
y hagan que esta fecha límite sea más
cercana pero si no es un mercado
inmobiliario muy deseado no necesitan
hacer todas estas modificaciones ya que
es bastante prudente
asegurarse de tener todas estas
contingencias para no decepcionarse
después de que compren la casa